hey
time to stand together like once before
and this time we'll stop the war
habanero
[Music]
i'm from saudi arabia and i live in los
angeles california
[Music]
i love music because when i perform
it feels so free he said he was a danger
he ruined his last name his daughter
she's a singer put
i grew up in a more conservative society
and music
is not really seen as a career from
where where i come from
it's scary you know when you put
yourself out there and you come from a
place where it's not typical to put
yourself out there especially being a
woman that's why i wrote gender game
and so i see myself as a bridge
between people's perceptions of the
middle east and people's perceptions of
the west
there are so many positive things that
are happening in saudi with women women
can now vote in the municipal elections
more women are working and they're
independent women can't drive yet but i
do have hope and i know that it's going
to happen soon
we need to remember that when we're
thinking about somebody else
when we don't like what another culture
is doing we need to take a step back and
remember that we're all human beings
you